from Politico RFK Jr super pack raises
$1 million within hours and courts Elon
musk's support just hours after RFK Jr
announced he would run for president as
an independent more than 11 million
gushed into the coffers of a super pack
supporting him American values 2024 said
it raised 11.28 million in just 6 hours
following Kennedy's announcement in
Philadelphia on indigenous people's day
are they seriously going with that
Politico I it's Columbus day isn't
it
according to press release millions of
independent-minded Americans are seeing
through the most powerful censorship and
propaganda campaign against any
candidate in American political history
said Tony Lions co-founder of the pack
in a press release they are angry at the
DNC for attempting to disenfranchise
them eager to support an honest Democrat
and more open than ever before in
American history to an independent and
honest candidate so uh I guess I'll just
throw it to you Max I'm curious what
your thoughts are on RFK uh RFK Jor is
announcing he's running do you like the
guy do you think he's going to pull
votes from Biden or Trump I mean I
personally like him I really hit it off
with him I felt like he was a
like-minded person when I met with him
and I've been interviewed by him he's
completely woke in the good way of woke
on Ukraine on issues of on Iraq
Afghanistan and his opening speech for
his campaign was in many ways inspiring
I mean I thought it was a great anti-war
speech and he brought up his uncle's uh
wish to scatter the CIA into a thousand
pieces
I me that was the message we needed to
hear since then his campaign has been
completely deflated within the anti-war
movement since he took on this uh ludik
kind of Extreme pro-israel Dimension to
it which and started to seem like he was
agitating for war with Iran didn't seem
in his speech yeah yeah I mean if you
watch he did this weird event with Shmi
boti who's this kind of like Rabbi runs
around calling everyone an anti-s semi
who won't do what he wants um he's paid
by Sheldon Adon who was one of the
biggest individual donors to Trump who
came in through Jared Kushner and it was
a weird event I was like did you get
paid to do that like is there some kind
of incentive for you to take on this non
anti-war line because you see I mean if
if you're that pro-israel you're not
going to like hang out with me you know
who I am and it just seemed strange to
me so I there's just been this feeling
of deflation Within kind of anti-war
movement anti-war Independent Media uh
within the sectors of the left that
initially supported him the Grassroots
left and yeah the Democrats were always
going to screw him over yeah and now the
question is what is he going to do as an
independent because we knew we know he
was one of the boldest people in America
speaking out against the propaganda and
scoping of the country during the coid
event that would seem to drain from
Donald Trump if he was in independent or
whoever the Republican a disantis and
I've I mean hasn't he I've heard that
one of his his recent rallies he's been
attacking Trump in a more strident way
so well it's it's unclear what he's
trying to do here but you're you're
you're not you're not voting for
him I I I mean I I I can't see myself
doing that but I I don't really it
doesn't matter who I vote for because I
live in DC well sure sure but I mean in
terms of your your moral compass and
your heart uh if
if Trump beats Biden how does that make
you feel or if Biden beats Trump like do
does it matter to
you I mean it it it matters but I I mean
I'm not I can't see myself voting for
either of them but what I I mean just
looking at it from a more objective
point of view not
me I think this election is so much
about whether you trust the system or
not a lot of and so many people who just
simply don't trust a system are going to
vote for Trump just to give the finger
to the system because not because they
like him uh the indictments a lot of
people who've been screwed over by the
criminal justice system who are not
traditional Republicans are starting to
sympathize with him the things he says
about the system about the Deep State
the National Security State um the media
everybody hates the media it's the it's
the worst I mean having been in the
media for 20 years it's like you get all
the worst people in the country in one
place and then just let them go crazy
and dominate your mind so Trump is the I
mean I I I loved when he would call the
media the corporate media the enemy of
the people so this and this is all this
is about that and the people who have
the most to lose from the loss of
establishment control
financially tend to be the Democratic
party donor class I think so I think I
think he's you you can't pull from Trump
for the reasons you just described I
mean my my my attitude toward Trump is I
I just think he's the best bet in terms
of firing people you know I I think
Ronda sandz is a negotiator I I I like a
lot of his policies I think he's running
a bad campaign and I think he goes to DC
and then he just says you know let's
let's just negotiate and play ball
unemployment yeah Donald Trump I think
is just at this point he wants revenge
that's the joke we make we made the
poster of him that says revenge on it
and if he fires a bunch of people I'll
take what I can get I don't like when it
was Trump versus Hillary I just thought
it I thought it was WWE it was garbage
like Hillary Clinton is a psychopath
she's a sociopath she wants to murder
people she was the she was Secretary of
State under Obama and all of that
Bloodshed I'm like Libya yeah I'm in New
York you're not getting me to vote for
this lady even Obama knew she was crazy
yeah dude yeah he wouldn't let her buddy
Sydney Blumenthal work with uh uh in the
government and Sydney's like a Gunrunner
he he wanted to set up ospr Global
Solutions in Libya and he was like a
longtime adviser of the clintons and
Obama's like I don't want him anywhere
near here Hillary but she was having
secret emails with him and like doing
what he wanted to get his company set up
in Libya when we took over just a dirty
dirty dirty woman but I mean I I wonder
if uh I mean I I I have to feel like
you're not a trump guy but you'd have to
think Trump is better than
Biden um I don't think Trump is better
than Biden based on him bringing okay I
know I know Bolton what do you mean
better than Biden well I mean look Joe
Biden is the perpetuation of the
establishment warmonger Warhawk garbage
neol neocon machine and Donald Trump is
an extremely imperfect loudmouth who at
least told us a bit of the truth tried
to get our troops out of Afghanistan and
Syria and no new Wars so if it's like if
you don't like his policies if you don't
like his character if you don't like his
attitude I I can I understand this
libertarian argument where they're like
Trump is bad here are all the really bad
things he did and I'm like and isn't
doesn't it suck that he was better than
all the rest and they're like well
that's not saying much I'm like but it
is saying something I mean there were
things Trump did that I found absolutely
horrible like trillion dollar tax cut
is from where I'm coming from it's it's
just uh fueling the economic crisis
people are in and where I live in w 8
and DC I mean you just see total
desperation there is no program no
there's no social safety net for anyone
and it's fueling homicide people just
don't care anymore Donald Trump did some
off you know he he brought John Bolton
in he brought Nikki Haley in he brought
HR McMaster in he brought Jared Kushner
in he let Ivanka show him pictures of
Syrian children supposedly and then
acted on a false flag to fire missiles
so can you really trust him obvious what
the establishment is afraid of with
Trump is not what he does it's what he
says yeah and then with Biden well we
see what we get with
Biden and seriously and to your and and
to your point before I mean you know you
should play the man not the ball I mean
I you should judge you can judge me uh
based on my work and the things I do I
think that's only fair I think all those
criticisms of trump are absolutely Fair
yeah and then it's still like he crossed
the DMZ into North Korea and it's like
no new Wars perpetuation of Wars for
sure uh an effort to wind down and get
us out of Afghanistan when he brought
the Taliban to Camp David he got
attacked for it and I'm like negotiate
negotiate we're done with this and uh he
tried getting our troops out of Syria
except for the oil and they lied to the
American people about it and my attitude
is just I'm not saying you have to
support him or like him but it's like
and you don't have to comment at all
that's up to you I'm just saying for me
I look at it like yeah Trump may be in
general bad I don't know if a president
could be good but he's better than that
than he's the best president I've had in
my life no I understand why people feel
that way as a journalist I'm just not
going to be drawn into being like a
court voice for a candidate it's because
they're always going to disappoint you
what Trump shows is just he he he lifts
the mask on the fact that there is what
you could call a deep State I I just
just loved when he was in it was like he
was in front of the helicopter or
whatever and he was like we're doing
this weapons deal with Syria it's going
to be great for the ecademy and then all
the anti-war left they were just like he
just said it he just came out and said
it what did he do with the Drone weapon
program uh Luke was saying on the show
that he gave control of the Drone
assaults to the generals like so he he
no longer made the decision of who's
going to die he just so he's like he
kind of washed his hands of it and gave
what what was that exact I mean I know
that he gave the CIA unpress precedented
powers to carry out Black Operations
including assassinations um the CIA Lo
which is funny because the CIA also was
working against Trump and I mean John
Brennan was running Russia gate and once
you're in the CIA you're always in the
CIA like John Brennan being former CIA
and then going on MSNBC and calling
Trump a traitor that's the C he's
speaking for a wing of the CIA but
meanwhile the Black Ops guys in the CIA
were getting to do whatever they wanted
so that's not cool yeah I mean they say
no new Wars but he empowered the Deep
state by giving CIA authority to do
Secret assassinations and he also the
Abraham Accords on their face sound neat
but like you were saying earlier it it
put the Palestinian people in in an ice
box and gave the like the Kings of
Israel and Saudi Arabia actual is not
literal Kings but the the leaders I
should say Emirates and the wahabi
forces like the most backwards forces in
the Middle East who are the least
Democratic we're going to get a complete
win-win situation under the Abraham
Accords but so much for that but so I I
just don't I don't think you can trust
what Trump will will do it was his
Personnel that really I think he'll fire
people his personal choices were
abysmal what happens if he fires people
what happens if he really starts
draining the swamp what happens if he um
goes into the state department and just
just like you're all out of here no more
USA ID none of this crap oh FBI uh
you're all you're actually going you
guys are going on trial wiretapping me
send them all to an Alaska I feel bad
for the people of an Alaska when I say I
was so depressed I followed a BLM March
a Pennsylvania a and I and they walked
right by the Jay Edgar Hoover FBI
building as if it didn't even exist and
I was like that's how I knew this whole
thing was this is the guy that like wire
tap Martin Luther King just like we're
gonna go somewhere but anyway if Trump
did that I know from a source who was
like down with Trump that one of Trump's
greatest fears was assassination
I wouldn't be surprised he the new
report is that he's he he only uses
individual bottles of ketchup that are
sealed he is not as dumb as I thought
and uh and and uh I knew people that
were on the campaign trail with him in
2015 said he only needs McDonald's and
the joke was he just loves fast food no
the issue is that when you walk into
McDonald's the burger is already made
and you can say that one right there and
you know it's not been tampered with
whereas if you go to most restaurants
who knows what they're doing so you
saying the assumption is that if he
tried to fire everybody they'd kill him
well take Reagan being shot by John H
Ley to impress jod Foster out of the
equation when was the last political
assassination significant political
assassination in this country do you
mean like admitted and acknowledged yeah
acknowledged cuz acknowledged we like
then we'll then we'll skip over JFK and
we'll well we I mean there were more
recent ones than that George Wallace oh
oh sure yeah right okay George Wallace
was running as I think an independent
candidate in 72 and he was going to harm
Nixon because he had a lot of Republican
you know Southern support so he gets
taken out so you think Kennedy's at
risk the Kennedy family the Kennedy
family history is not is not you know
confidence building I don't think the
Democrats are threatened by him right
now that's my sense especially as an
independent I don't and I don't think
they're threatened by Cornell West I
think Cornell West effectively dropped
out of the race yeah and he just wants
to have a platform to go around giving
talks on the show he's pretty cool yeah
he's a cool very wonderful human being
but he doesn't have a platform right he
just makes Proclamation ations and uses
a lot of isms is disappointing to me
because he's someone I have so much
common ground with but I don't think
there's a threat right now to the
establishment other than Trump and
obviously Trump's kind of like the front
runner so what will they do if he
actually fulfills those promises if he
goes like dark Brandon
[Laughter]
Trump is that a rhetorical question I
mean yeah I'm just putting it out on the
table so I don't have to do Alex Jones
said that his would go down and a plane
crash that's how that they would kill
him I don't know and like a lot of
people would
celebrate that would be thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net